Belfast is clearly a very popular
destination right now you had President
Biden visiting last week along with the
prime minister
the clintons yesterday
the Prime Minister liked it so much he's
back again this week
and me today lucky you
but of course this city was a Natural
Choice to hold a cyber conference
it's become a global hotspot for cyber
and tech companies including IBM
security
Microsoft and Nvidia
and we're meeting at a very interesting
time for cyber in the United Kingdom
interesting
because we have a prime minister and a
government that is deeply passionate
about Science and Tech and has put it
front and center of our agenda
interesting because we have a thriving
Tech sector to match and because
government and Industry are building a
strong partnership through the new
National cyber Advisory Board which I
will be co-chairing again this afternoon
with Sharon Barber from Lloyd's
but it is also an interesting time
because of the world we live in today
the last time cyber UK was held last May
attendees were gathering in the shadow
of Russia's unprovoked invasion of
Ukraine
and the brutal reality is that a year on
we continue to live in a more dangerous
more volatile world
one that has far-reaching consequences
for the British people
now that's partly a consequence of
Russia's aggression
it's partly because of the growing
economic coercion of other countries
and it's also because of the way that
climate change and Technology continue
to transform and disrupt our world
all of those things are putting our
systems under more pressure than ever
before
and so in government we are devoting a
lot of time and energy on how we can
improve the resilience of the government
in the face of those and future
challenges
now many of you will have seen that a
few weeks ago the government published a
refresh of our defense and National
Security strategy the integrated review
setting out how we intend to fortify our
national defenses against the challenges
both today and tomorrow
and it's something that the Prime
Minister has asked me to lead on from
the cabinet office particularly when it
comes to Economic Security and
bolstering our national resilience
so I wanted to use this opportunity
today to take you through how that
applies to cyber security
where I think we are as a country and
what the government intends to do to
make sure we stay ahead of our
adversaries every step of the way
it's been a couple of months since the
world was gripped by the progress of
that Chinese balloon floating across the
skies of the United States now as I'm
sure you'll recall that spy balloon
dominated the headlines because it was a
very visible symbol of America's borders
being breached by an Uninvited Guest
and yet every day a combination of
criminals
Spooks hacktivists and cyber soldiers
silently and invisibly breach our
digital defenses both in the United
Kingdom and in the rest of the world and
we saw it earlier this year with raw
mail when a ransomware attack disrupted
overseas deliveries for weeks
and last August when an attack on a
third-party supplier caused severe
disruption to nhs11
so what does the overall cyber threat to
the UK look like today
well according to the latest assessments
from the national cyber security Center
the most acute State threats in
cyberspace continue to come from those
Usual Suspects Russia China Iran and
North Korea
the NSC ncsc are also devoting a lot of
their energy today to defending
democracy
including by tackling threats against
both the conservative party leadership
contest last year
and the recent Scottish national party
leadership contest both of which took
place online
and there is another new front opening
as we see more and more adversaries able
to buy and sell sophisticated cyber
tools and spyware like Pegasus
these are the types of tools that we
used to only see in a handful of State
actors and which can cause serious
damage
so it's something we're taking very
seriously and to which we are responding
with our International partners
meanwhile cyber crime is estimated to
cost the UK billions of pounds each year
according to new figures published today
32 of UK businesses and Charities
suffered a cyber breach or attack in the
past year that is a third of our
businesses
and ransomware continues to run rampant
and as prime minister as President Biden
rightly recognized a few weeks ago
thanks to its scale and its impact
ransomware is no longer just a crime
it's a national security threat
and our response needs to reflect the
severity of that threat
these are attacks on our citizens
our businesses and our democracy
they are an attempt to undermine our
society and we are determined to stop
them with your help
in the UK we grasped the need for Urgent
action early and we've been doing a lot
over the past few years to strengthen
our cyber defenses
we have published the national cyber
strategy and we have a new and effective
cyber sanctions regime which we recently
used for the first time against a group
of Russian cyber criminals as part of a
joint campaign with the United States
and we're working closely with
International Partners to tackle the
proliferation of sophisticated
commercial cyber tools
at the same time the government itself
continues to face a range of attacks
including ransomware and Espionage and
so we are constantly looking to
strengthen our cyber defenses
and as part of that today I can announce
that we are launching gov ashore a
transformational new Cyber regime for
the whole of government Governor Shaw
will be rolled out across White Hall it
will be used to assess every Department
cyber Health on an annual basis against
stringent new measures so that
government can better identify the risks
we face and make sure we are protecting
systems that help us run Public Services
so with each day as the threat evolves
so does our response
but a new adversary has emerged
over the last 18 months the national
cyber security Center has seen the rise
of several Russian aligned groups
sympathetic to Putin's invasion of
Ukraine
now these are Fringe State threats the
Cyber equivalent of the Wagner group
and initially those groups focused their
attacks on Ukraine and the surrounding
region
but recently they have begun to turn
their attention to the United Kingdom
and its allies
they are now seeking opportunities to
compromise our critical National
infrastructure
we have experienced attempted attacks in
the past
but these groups operate differently
instead of seeking to profit or spy on
us
their primary motive is to disrupt or
destroy our infrastructure
adversaries are ideologically motivated
rather than financially motivated
secondly
through these perpetrators though these
perpetrators are aligned to National
actors crucially they're often not
controlled by those foreign States
that makes them more opportunistic and
less likely to show restraint
together those factors make the current
situation particularly concerning
and so today I can confirm that the
national cyber security Center is
issuing an official alert to operators
of our critical National infrastructure
to highlight the risk they currently
face
that alert is now live on the ncsc's
website along with a number of
recommended actions that operators
should follow right now to increase
their resilience and help defend our
infrastructure against these attacks
this threat is not something we do
likely
this is an unprecedented warning for
business we've never publicly
highlighted the threat from these kinds
of groups attempting such attacks before
and I should stress that we do not think
that they currently have the capability
to cause widespread damage to our
infrastructure in the United Kingdom
but we do believe it is necessary at
this point of time if we want companies
to understand the threat they currently
face
and to take action to defend themselves
and the country against such attacks
this approach fits with that wider
National Security strategy
and last year
when we saw that Russian forces were
gathering at the Ukrainian border we
Declassified the information to let the
world see what they were doing
today with cyber threats you will
increasingly see us say what we are
seeing we won't allow these groups to
stay in the shadows we're shining a
light on these threats because we need
to work together to strengthen our
defenses
that means that businesses need to see
the threats clearly too
and over the last few years we've done
lots of things to make it easier for
businesses to secure themselves
including issuing world-leading guidance
offering threats assessments underpinned
by intelligence
I'm providing key early warning services
like the early warning system
but given the constantly evolving cyber
threat I believe this is the right
moment to look at our cyber defenses
more widely particularly when it comes
to those of our businesses
the reality is that we in government can
only do so much business is large and
small sit on the front line of our cyber
defenses they face attacks on a daily
basis and any Gap in that front line
leaves us all vulnerable
and when we published the national cyber
strategy just over a year ago
we said we would review the government's
ability to hold operators of critical
National infrastructure to account
I've concluded now that we do need to go
further
so today I can confirm that I will be
setting specific and ambitious cyber
resilience targets for all critical
National infrastructure sectors to meet
by 2025
and that I'm actively examining plans to
bring all private sector businesses
working in critical National
infrastructure within the scope of cyber
resilience regulations
these are the companies in charge of
keeping our country running of keeping
the lights on
our shared Prosperity depends on them
taking their own security seriously and
that extends to their cyber security
a bricks and mortar business wouldn't
survive if it left the back door open to
criminals every night
quilly in today's Digital World
businesses can't afford to recklessly
ignore cyber risks either
to leave their digital back door open to
cyber Crux and hackers
and while we're doing this to combat
certain risks there is also a real
opportunity for our businesses
we have a huge amount to gain by making
the United Kingdom the safest country in
the world to do business
because the fact is that in today's
modern world prosperity and economic
security go hand in hand you cannot have
the former without the latter
investors want to put their money in a
safe country in businesses that take
security seriously
so the safer we make our defenses the
safer we make our country and the more
attractive we become as a destination
for entrepreneurs and investors all over
the world
and the fact that the UK has taken in
the last few years cyber security so
seriously already makes us one of the
best places in the world to invest
so this is my Call to Arms for
businesses
look again at your security
strengthen it wherever you can the
stronger your business the stronger our
economy and the more prosperous we
become together
and in turn we in government will
continue to do as much as we can to
support the Cyber industry and
businesses more widely
and so finally I just want to outline
how we are fulfilling our part of this
partnership
cyber is an industry that continues to
grow in every sense new figures show
that it is worth more it adds more
companies and it employs more people
than this time last year in 2022
revenues hit over ten and a half billion
pounds the saturnshire attracted 300
million pounds of investment and it
added an additional 5 300 jobs in that
time
at a time of Global Market uncertainty
the industry really is looking very
strong and through our cyber Runway
program we've helped over 160 cyber
security companies and startups grow and
develop their businesses
and there is even more room for growth
given that we currently face a shortfall
of around 14
000 cyber Security Professionals each
year in the United Kingdom
the jobs are there we just need to give
people the skills to fill them which is
what we're trying to do in government
through things like cyberfirst and cyber
explorers and indeed I saw this with my
own eyes a few weeks ago when I spent
time with students at the University of
South wales's cyber Academy
I watch them at their computers going
through the Cyber equivalent of football
drills practicing attack and defense
and through academies like that we are
building the UK's cyber talent pool for
the future and on Monday you may have
heard the Prime Minister launched a
major drive to improve math skills
across the country and as he said in
that speech numeracy is the foundation
of the modern economy today it's just as
essential as being able to read and it
is particularly vital if we want people
to be able to take up jobs in cyber Tech
and Beyond
we also recognize that as a major
employer of cyber Security Professionals
across the UK the government needs to do
more to attack the very best talents now
like many of you I noted the recent
debate around the salary offered for a
cyber role in government uh
of course people who work for government
will always be motivated by public
service
but a cyber specialist knows they can
earn five to seven times if not more for
the same role in the private sector
and the government needs to break
through its own glass ceiling so I am
also examining
what more we can do to improve salaries
and other parts of that offer so that we
really can continue to attract the very
best cyber experts into the Civil
Service these are the people protecting
the systems and public services that
millions of people across the country
rely on every day so we should want the
very best people in charge of them we
must be competitive to stay ahead
so
we are Keen to do our bit
and for the private sector in turn to do
its bit
to defend us one
so that we can prosper as one
and as I have set out the government is
clear-eyed about the challenges that we
face
we need businesses
to be clear in their determination to
meet those challenges with us
it's not going to be easy
and these threats won't disappear
overnight
but by working together I believe that
when we meet next year at Cyber UK 2024
the UK will be more resilient and more
secure thank you
[Applause]